- Hey, guys it's GaryVee
on a Monday morning.
Still feeling the effects
of an incredible episode
four of Trash Talk.
If you haven't been following along,
we're back after a long hiatus.
Josh, you're confused my friend.
I'm a winner, you root for winners, dick.
- [Josh] Yeah, that's true, very true.
- Trash Talk is a show where
I go and turn trash into cash.
(upbeat music)
♪ C'mon and groove along ♪
- Trash Talk episode four.
Soon, episode five.
♪ Hit it ♪
♪ That's what I'm talking about ♪
♪ Wait ♪
♪ Okay now, from the beginning ♪
(jazz music)
- I mean there's so many
things going on here,
I see all sorts of action.
I want a piece of the action.
- I'm just about that action, boss.
- Just gonna, (laughs)
gonna go randomly into people's homes.
Hey, Instagram, I'm in
somebody's house, randomly.
Okay, first sale of the day.
♪ This is my country, my damn country ♪
♪ Give me my country,
you can keep the rest ♪
♪ This is my country, my damn country ♪
- First two sales, garbage.
(upbeat music)
All right let's see what's going on here.
- [Lady] $5.
- $5?
- I thought she was a little bit unfair.
- I wanted the mug, but she
was like mean mugging me.
- Trash Talk, episode four.
Bang, I see it and I'm feeling hot.
Pull up right here, show him.
This woman's got no chance.
This lady's got no chance.
Do you have any sports
cards or video games?
- No, no.
- Okay, that's devastating.
DRock, let's try
something, can you hear me?
Shake your head, amazing.
This is gonna be the
new part of Trash Talk,
invention, episode four.
Can you have Little Lou
look up UNICEF mugs?
U-N-I-C-E-F.
Feel like there's something here,
that I'm not understanding.
This squirrel's cute as shit.
It's a cute-ass, it's a cute-ass squirrel.
(laughing)
I'm gonna take these two mugs.
- Sure.
- Thank you, darling.
- [Lady] Okay, thank you.
- Have a great day.
- Have a great day, you too.
Feeling really good about
myself and that mug life.
You know how we live it, mug
life, motherfucker, mug life.
- [DRock] It's early.
- It's very early, but I'm panicking.
Oh for four.
♪ Who would you tell
'cause I wouldn't tell ♪
- I'm making something happen here.
♪ Of you and what you can get done to me ♪
- Good morning.
Have a good day.
- You too.
- Fucking beyond frustrating.
First half an hour of Trash
Talk episode four, disastrous,
but this is where you
gotta be patient, kids.
You gotta patience in
life and you need patience
in garage saling.
I will say, I'm easily
more patient in life
than I am in garage selling,
I'm already panicking.
Get hot, please get hot.
You don't have any video games, do you?
- Video games?
- Video games.
- [Woman] Yeah we do, what kind?
- Like Nintendo games or?
- Oh, yeah.
- I saw the Guitar Hero thing, not that.
DRock, they see you, brother.
(laughs)
All right, good news, we got action.
DS games, and the good stuff.
Sonic, show me some more stuff, Sonic,
Zelda, Sonic, Pokemon, Sonic.
Let's look it up.
- [Lou] And this is Mario and Sonic.
- Let's go!
All right, huge hit I paid
10 bucks for five DS games.
We are looking them up right now,
boom, right off the bat,
40 bucks for this Zelda.
25 for this Sonic, let's
go to the next one.
Hold on, let's go, no, I got
the ones that were right.
I know how to bye, Little Lou.
I passed on the games
that aren't worth as much.
I can't, we're not spellers, Lou.
- We're not spellers.
- We're not spellers, we're
sellers, mother fucker.
Bang, (laughs) let's go, Lou.
What you didn't see 'cause I sat on my mic
was that she wanted five bucks a piece
and I negotiated down to two
so from 25 to 10 and then
the 100 plus come up,
negotiation, it's key.
- [Lou] You're going up
and you're making a left.
(phone rings)
- Hey, bro.
- Sis, just destroyed it,
just paid 10 bucks for five DS games,
at least 125 bucks profit.
- No.
- Yeah, it's all out here
and like people are complaining, you know.
- [Liz] Listen, I have to
go to Anne's birthday party.
Believe me, when you called I was like,
dammit, he got something good.
(laughs)
- I love you.
- [Liz] Love you, have fun, send a pic.
- I got pics, check my
Instagram story, I'm killin' it.
- [Liz] All right, love you.
Hi guys, love you, love you, bye.
- Bye.
- Uh oh, closed like it's my job.
Damn, this guy's taking
a guitar, look at 'em.
He's stealing that guitar,
that guy right there's
stealing that guitar.
He's playing her into a coma,
he's tricking her into a coma.
VHS is such an interesting thing.
Little Lou, can you hear me?
Gremlins, original Gremlins, 1985, yeah.
Yes, really?
Jesus Christ, I'm about to
buy a fuck load of VHS tapes.
I don't wanna do this and
I can feel it's happening.
- Okay, thank you.
- That lady flexed on the other lady.
She's like, don't buy these,
we got a library full of VHSs for free.
- [Lou] Why would she do that?
- 'Cause she's a gangster.
- No she's not.
- She's a hater!
♪ I got no pics on Kairi
New Glock 9 on my hip, ♪
♪ You get clipped if you reachin' ♪
♪ Make the bartender send
you a shot or some bleach ♪
♪ We gon' make you go
viral, you cry like Tyrese ♪
♪ You say my name on a single,
my niggas gon' lean you, ♪
♪ we'll be at your album release ♪
♪ Jay might pick me up,
we just got him a Jeep ♪
♪ Dre Mac called me my phone,
said he got him some freaks ♪
- Look, Jordan's.
But I'm not buyin' that
fuck face's sneakers.
Get a load of this.
- [DRock] What, the light?
- Just me always going through
yellows is key. (laughs)
Never stop at yellow, ever.
That's the difference between
an entrepreneur and an employee.
- Well, sometimes stop.
- Never, never.
You've got more time
than you think, DRock.
♪ Grind it like I'm DJ Mustard ♪
♪ I got your bitch all
through the gutter, ♪
♪ I just told her bust it ♪
♪ We got them sticks on
us in public I cannot ♪
- No way, the audio went out?
- Yep.
- So the audio went out,
what I was just saying was
we just bought an entire box
of Nerf guns for 20 bucks,
it was pretty nasty, an amazing deal,
we'll be looking those up shortly.
♪ Winter ♪
- What do you think?
- [DRock] Yeah, it feels better already.
- Really, seriously?
- Yeah.
I don't hear any static at all, zero.
- Which is huge, where the fuck?
(laughs)
That was amazing.
- Got that open.
- Yeah.
Instagram, you're not gonna believe this,
just bought a massive amount of Nerf guns,
like ridiculous amounts.
Little Lou, I need you
to start looking these up
while I go in this next sale,
I think these are just absurd.
All right guys, now we're
starting to get somewhere, right.
You filming?
- Yeah.
- We're getting somewhere now.
What's cool is this car, this
might be a really good deal,
might have to do something with that.
- How are you doing?
- Good, bro, how are you?
- Good, how are you?
- Doin' well.
Worried about the look of this.
I love whales.
- I love lamp.
- They just swag.
Fuck.
Is the car for sale?
- No, it's not.
- No.
- [Resident] Yeah, I'm
sorry, it's a 1966 Mustang.
- It's fucking fresh.
- [Resident] Yeah, it's
on top of a truck frame,
it's a 67 Chevy Blazer frame,
so it's a four by four
but with the Mustang top.
- You roll with it?
- Once in awhile, and if my
dad let's me take it out.
- When you wanna flex.
- Yeah.
- Great, that was a
devastating garage sale,
however, meanwhile back at the trunk
Little Lou is looking up the Nerf guns
and I'm feeling really good about this.
He might not know how to do it,
but I'm feeling great about it.
Lou?
- These three is 33.
- What's that?
- Just these three is 33 bucks.
- How much is this one?
- 10.
- 25.
- All right so, like bring
this out, the bow and arrow,
how'd you not look up the bow, I mean,
how'd you not look this up yet?
I mean, this fuckin' thing is a flexer.
This is 25, it's only one of
the 30 guns that we bought,
we paid 20.
- [Lou] You made that money
back on the first gun.
That was the first one I pulled out,
I was like, all right, you
already made the money back.
- Yeah, of, well, fees and all of that,
let's keep this honest, but net net,
this 20 is easily gonna be,
it's gonna be 200, it just is.
That looks like garbage,
that looks like garbage
McGee but we'll try.
(rock music)
Fuck.
What about this one?
Surprise?
- Yeah, he's right, he's
right, good shit, Lou.
- [Lou] This isn't Trash
Talk episode one, guys.
- This is episode four, Lou knows.
- [Lou] This is episode
four, I have a map.
- I saw the, I have a map.
- I have a map.
- Guys, map one, Gary zero.
Like, put up the fuckin' icon,
put it up, map one, Gary zero.
- [Lou] The map doesn't lie.
♪ I'm the map I'm the map I'm the map ♪
- Maps don't lie.
- [Lou] They never lie, it's impossible.
- Let's see what's going on
here, this feels terrible.
This is, I'm not even,
I'm not even going there.
Oh, I am, holy shit.
Excuse me.
How much is the Jets coat?
- [Gary] The Jets coat?
- [Gary] So fuckin' cool.
Fuck, I love this coat.
Shit, I love this coat.
- [Gary] I hate to insult,
but it's a big difference
between where you're at and where I'm at.
- [Gary] What's that, brother?
- [Gary] 10?
- [Gary] I would do 10.
Got a nice day, huh?
- Beautiful one.
- Gorgeous.
Cards.
- [Gary] Brother, I got
so much of this shit,
it's crazy how it worked out, you know?
It felt so good at the time but--
- [Gary] Yeah, yeah that's right.
- [Gary] I appreciate that,
that's awesome, thank you.
- [Gary] Yeah. (laughs)
Do you have a 10?
- Yeah, I sure do
- Thank you.
- Two fives.
- [Gary] How much are the video games?
- [Gary] Would you do for these three 10
so I can just give you the 20?
Thank you guys, have a wonderful day.
- You too.
- Take care of yourself.
Holy shit, thanks so much.
Holy shit, no audio, you got audio?
Did you not have it?
Did you have it the whole time?
Holy shit.
Holy shit, let's get somewhere
'cause something amazing just happened.
Holy shit.
Lou, do you see what you're
holding in your hand?
- [Lou] Yeah, I do.
- Do you know how much that is worth?
- [Lou] No.
- I cannot believe what just happened.
- [DRock] The coat?
- No, not the fuckin'
coat, the Zelda games.
Let's go, let's go!
I'm fired up, I'm going
faster, I'm fired up,
let's go, this is huge.
This is monumental,
let's get to a nice place
and record this post game.
Holy shit, we hit big, fuckin' big, DRock,
and Drock's audio worked the whole time.
It's a huge score, I'm
super fired up, here we go.
- And here's the jacket.
- Thank you.
So first you're gonna see
that I negotiated heavy.
(thuds)
- Oh--
- My gosh.
- Chill.
- What are you talking about,
you just broke the whole game?
- I broke the game?
They look fine.
- All right, what you're
gonna see first is
I scored a massive Jets retro jacket,
he wanted 25, he didn't
get it, he didn't get it,
and then he wanted 15, and he
didn't get that either, baby,
10 bucks for Jets vintage,
I'm gonna wear it myself,
that's not even going for sale.
All right, let's just nail this down,
paid 3.33 for each 'cause
I got these three for 10,
you'll see the whole thing,
I paid 20 for the Jets jacket
and the three Links and
fuckin' the Links are,
let's call it 50, 25, 25,
so 100 just for those.
That Jets jacket, if that
wasn't hanging out there
I wouldn't've stopped and
would've never gotten the Zelda.
That's why you always have to, man,
guys, never listen to your
intuition, always see it through.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
(laughs)
- [Lou] Last night when he was like,
I should've trusted my gut.
- Caleb, you gotta use that.
I shoulda followed my gut
on the last other places.
Follow your gut, kids.
Never just go on intuition,
see it all the way through.
That's why the answer's always both.
- Never listen to yourself.
- I mean this has got no shot.
- But, or.
- Or,
there are stuffed animals.
Here we go, fuck, this
guy's got a Patriots hat on.
This lady's trying to take all my shit.
How much are the stuffed animals?
- [Man] The big ones are a dollar
and the small ones are three for a dollar.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Gary] For the Yankees
for a dollar I'll do that.
This is cute as shit, I'm
gonna try this one too.
These are cute.
All right, three dollars.
- How do you wanna do this?
- [Gary] It seems like this
goes with these two, right?
Yep, got it.
- Okay.
- Two, three.
- Yep.
- Awesome, you got a bag?
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
This I like, DRock.
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
- The guy back there, he
was wearing a Patriots hat
so I had to fuckin' rip
his fuckin' face off
for all my pent up anger about football.
(laughs)
Now let's look up these Yankee bears
which I got three for a dollar,
let's see what they're worth,
and this cute little husky
with his little baby,
and the little black dog with
his baby, let's look it up.
Bang, 1999.
- Wow.
- Good with mic?
- Yeah.
- Here we go, continue the hot streak.
Hello.
- Hello there.
- Shit.
All right, we were hot, I mean,
there was no way I could
be upset about that.
Let's see what happens here.
Have a great day, guys, take care!
- Bye.
- Thank you.
Here we go, four dollar tire.
- [Man] Do I hear a five?
- This one has potential.
- Hi, how are you
- Hello.
- [Woman] How are you?
- I'm super well, how are you guys?
- [Man] No, but do you
know who this is, GaryVee?
(laughs)
- What's up, bro?
- How you doin'?
- Good, man.
- That's crazy,
I was just watching your
videos on Instagram right now.
- [Gary] Thank you, bro, thank
you bro, what's your name?
Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, man.
- All well?
- Anything good here?
- [Gary] I'm not sure, I'm
trying to figure it out.
- You're out garage saling?
- I'm garage saling, yeah.
Doin' that big, you doin' well?
- Yeah, doin' well.
- Good, man.
Thanks for the love.
- Of course.
- [Gary] This guy's cramming my style.
- Pleasure meeting you.
- Thank you, bro.
- [Gary] Get outta here
so I can do my thing.
Yes, keep going, you get outta
here and I can do my thing.
How much is this poster?
- Five.
- Five?
- Would you do three?
Cool.
I can't believe I'm
fuckin' buying this thing,
I just can't let it go,
it's probably worth 100.
Son of a bitch, I'm so pissed right now.
I don't even wanna touch it.
Lou, can you come here and get it.
Oh boy.
I didn't wanna grab it
but I had to get it.
Business is business.
There's a chance that the
poster I just bought is $220.
I think that's it, I just had a feeling,
Drock, film this whole thing,
we passed the garage sale,
I wasn't gonna turn around,
and then I just let my feelings
take over, that's the U-ey.
This could be huge, or it could
be a waste of four minutes
and that is also huge, this is huge,
it's a on Helen Ave, it's a dead end,
get it DRock, Helen Ave, dead end.
There we go.
Awkward looks, all sorts
of things happening here.
Think I've made a devastating mistake.
God dammit.
- Like look it, Trash Talk
episode four, I've heard it,
like I've read the comments,
like people are like,
oh, what about the fuel,
what about the eBay fees,
what about the shipping?
What about it, like, fuel costs money,
every business costs money,
it costs you fuel to go to work too.
Like, everything costs money, right?
Shipping, charge them shipping,
incorporate that into your costs
or add $5 shipping, add $20 shipping,
or raise it by five bucks,
like shipping is business.
Took a little break, got a little snack,
got everybody settled,
now I need action, I need real action.
Beef jerky, protein, mother fucker.
Ghost Rider, legit.
Awesome.
Have a great day, guys,
take care, thank you.
Stay well, take care.
A high five from the guy was amazing.
You gotta do something funny
like go in the bushes one time,
see what happens.
Just go in through the bush from far away.
Well this one was too obvious but
I really think there's gonna be a scenario
where you're gonna be able to
do a going through the bushes.
Like, it would just be funny content,
like, you're in the bushes, right?
Some people I just love,
this is gonna be it.
You don't have any video games, do you?
- No.
- No, just mystery tapes.
- Cutest couple today, for
sure, were these peeps.
This lady was the best person
I've seen the whole time.
The best.
That lady was amazing.
She was like 100 and not giving a fuck.
She wasn't bullshitting.
Follow the yellow brick road,
follow the yellow brick road.
♪ Follow the yellow brick road ♪
- I feel like I'm Dorothy.
- Exactly like Dorothy.
- We're in the Wizard of Oz.
- I'm not sure but Lou
is definitely the Lion.
- I'm the what?
- The Lion.
Ooh, there stuff going on already.
Lou, come with me on this one?
This is not shaping up
to be what we wanted.
All right, let's go.
Double thumbs down, double thumbs down.
(laughs)
Double thumbs down.
Slap.
♪ Tell him if you know he got a stick ♪
♪ and you know he gon'
shoot 'bout me, yeah yeah ♪
- The same people who
are complaining about,
what about your fuel?
Are the ones that are
literally driving to work
for a $12 an hour job.
- [DRock] Or just going
out to see their friends.
- Well I don't even wanna talk
about their $4 Rolling Rock.
- $4 Rolling rock. (laughs)
- I mean it though,
people talkin' shit they don't have money
and buying fuckin' three
Rolling Rocks at a bar.
- [Lou] That killed me.
- Killed the Lion.
- Oh, the Lion.
All right, buying a $15 cocktail
and complaining about your
boss and your job, that's fine,
but driving around and
spending that same $15
on fuel all day hustling from
seven a.m. to 12 on a Saturday
to make 300 bucks, that you
gotta leave a fuckin' comment?
Okay, Johnnypants63, I feel you,
you're really scaring me off.
Look at this, looks like a lot going on.
- Lotta people here, for the record.
- How about standing behind
the tree, this tree right here.
- In their front yard?
- In their front yard.
Let's just make some funny content.
("The Pink Panther Theme")
- How are you doing?
- Good, bro, how are you?
How's it been going?
- [Man] Not too bad, steady crowd today.
- It's a nice day.
- Yeah.
- They see you, DRock.
Let's go back in.
- [Drock] So I stood behind the
tree and I was more obvious.
(laughs)
The guy's like.
- Yeah.
- What are doin'?
Student film.
- Student film. (laughs)
Student film!
♪ I'm getting money,
yeah, bitch, I'm a blood ♪
♪ Everybody know I bang that blood ♪
♪ Yeah, and I'm posted
on the block (Yeah) ♪
♪ One stop shop (Yeah) ♪
- This is rad.
- Had I known we still had this
while we're hanging out
barbecuing and getting shit faced
I would a busted that thing out.
- [Gary] Yeah, exactly.
- [Man] Its a lot of fun to play when
you're half in the bag.
- [Gary] Exactly.
- [Man] 'Cause it's not fun to play
when you're sober,
(laughs) this thing sucks!
- [Gary] But just get
a couple beers going.
- [Man] Right, with football
they're runnin' all over the place,
you know, you're guy's in the corner,
I'm like, this is taking forever.
- How's the sale been, good?
- It's all right.
- [Gary] Yeah, at least
you got a nice day.
- Yes.
- That's for sure.
- [Man] The Lord of the Rings goblets?
(laughs)
- [Gary] Take care, guys, stay well.
- Thank you.
- Nice truck, brother.
- Thank you so much, bro.
At least I made a best friend. (laughs)
- [DRock] I was like, really
brilliant job, he's a good guy.
- What the hell?
- What the?
- [Gary] That's rad.
♪ Ho you can't touch this, ayy ♪
♪ Bitch, I do rich shit, huh ♪
♪ My money thick thick, ayy ♪
♪ Walk with a limp, limp, huh ♪
- Here's the point, you're just seeing
what I wanna selectively pick up,
the reality if you really, really, really,
like if I really needed to make money
I would have a shitty truck right now
that doesn't guzzle gas
and I woulda made 500 to 1,000 already
'cause I woulda just bought everything.
This guy played chicken
with me, he lost, he lost.
Punked.
I was the aggressor.
These guys look like my competition.
- Yeah, that guy--
- Oh, he just got something.
What'd he get?
- I think he knows you.
I think he knows who I am, too.
He's making his own thing.
What's going on?
- How are you?
- [Gary] I'm well, you?
- Good.
- [Man] What's up.
- How are you?
- Good.
- Got a good score?
- Fuck yeah.
- [Gary] Let's go, what's up, bro?
- Nice to meet you.
- Gary.
How's the day been going?
- Good.
(imitates explosion)
That's awesome, man, have
a good time, take care.
Gotta watch out for the fans.
Winnie the Pooh's always in play.
- Ask her.
- Thank you.
- [Woman] $20.
- That is not where I
thought it was going.
God dammit, those He-Man books were legit.
I really thought it was gonna be awesome.
How are we not finding mugs?
- Wow, usually they are--
- Just no, I mean, we're finding
Nintendo games in package,
vintage Jets coats, but
we're not finding mugs.
DRock right now is hitting
up the rest of Team Gary
to try to, I got it, I
got it, make this right?
- Yep.
- I see the action now, I see it.
- [Lou] Very, very safe
what's happening right now.
- [Gary] What?
- Very safe what's going on.
- I'm fine.
♪ Money good, throw up where I'm from, ♪
♪ Let 'em know I'm still hood ♪
♪ I ain't had to get
nobody hit but I could ♪
♪ Before I post a pic, should
I flex, yeah, I should ♪
- [Gary] How much are these?
And these?
- [Gary] She knows too much.
My Little Ponies.
What would you do for all the ponies?
- [Gary] How many, did you count?
- [Gary] I'm gonna call my
sister, gimme a sec, thank you.
Do you want My Little Ponies?
I'll send you a picture.
You hearing all this, ah, Jesus.
Hello, I just sent you the pictures.
60, 60, right, ma'am, ma'am, 60?
- [Gary] Yeah, do you want 'em?
I love talking to myself at a garage sale.
Yeah, Trash Talk episode four,
trying to make the score
that really matters.
Yeah, I'll ask her.
Would you consider doing 40?
I'll take 'em.
- [Gary] I know.
I got the green light for 40.
(laughs)
Will you go 44?
All right, I don't think you guys heard me
because I know the sound went out
when I came back and went on speaker
but we ended up settling that deal for 50,
she wanted three bucks a piece,
I go, what do you want for all of it?
To try to context it, she counts 34
which gets to a hundo,
she comes in with 60,
Lou, what am I doing here?
- [Lou] Why's it blocking me off here?
- What's going on here,
I'm going through some sort of store.
- [Lou] Turn back around.
- I'm at a Starbucks, I'm
at the container store.
How the fuck did I end
up at a container store.
- [Lou] It like reset
on me, just turn around.
- Can do something weird
to get out of here?
- [Lou] No, you're going to the highway.
- Okay.
All right, she wanted a hundo,
she came in at 60 with the discount
so already we're in a good spot,
we're down to two bucks a pop,
even a little bit less right off the bat.
Sometimes when I wanna pay something,
I wanted to pay 40, I'll go like 30,
leave myself room to negotiate.
Other times I'll go in for
it quick so I went 40, boom,
this time it didn't work, then
I went with the awkward 44
to see what I could do with it
and then she just was emotional about 'em,
she said would you go
50, just such a good deal
for 34 original My Little
Ponies for 50 bucks,
wait til you see what
these go for individually,
it's pretty gnarly.
- [DRock] Can we talk about
the phone call to your sister?
- I'm gonna call my sister.
I love talking to myself at a garage sale.
Yeah, sometimes I'm trying to build
some narratives out there.
- [Lou] On the right side.
- Fill in some narratives out there
that might help me with my negotiation.
Guys, we hit it hard,
originally My Little Ponies,
34 of 'em, go to Lou, show it,
show it, 34 original ponies,
original My Little Ponies, early 80s.
- There's a lot of 'em.
- Like it's our job, wait til you see
what these things go for.
She wanted 100, she didn't get it,
she wanted 60, she didn't
get it, she got 50.
(chill music)
All right, we're heading to
the last sale of the day,
12:37 a.m.
Start at nine, three and a half
hours, did a ton of damage,
I mean, stuff that I haven't
been finding for a long time,
I used to flip ponies like crazy.
My Little Ponies was a
big part of my early days
of garage saling, found them,
Nintendo, big part, found
them, vintage Jets jacket.
I'm gonna wear this all the time.
Crushed on the Nerf guns.
Had to rip off that Patriot fan.
Like, this was a very accomplished day.
- Engle, right.
- I see it, thank you, Lou.
Going to Engle Road, Kurt
Angle, spelled differently.
("Medal")
Oof, good way to end,
looks like a big stack,
let's see if we can score.
- I don't know, maybe, might
be a nice way to wrap it up.
- Yeah, we gotta do. (laughs)
Okay, last sale, last sale of the day.
Didn't get any mugs,
which is disappointing.
Got like one in the beginning,
actually got mugs at the beginning but.
How much are the mugs?
- So now we found mugs, so pumped.
Milk too, milk mugs.
The Clapper.
Would you do a dollar for three?
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- Do you want a bag?
- Please.
There's nothing that excites me more
than 1980s girl's toys, memorabilia.
Picked up this Strawberry
Shortcake mug for 33 cents.
Roll down the window, DRock,
respect the game, Strawberry
Shortcake milk mug, what?
Mom and dad, milk mug, momma poppa.
Yo, first we picked up the ponies,
then we got Strawberry Shortcake,
it's 1980s girl life up in here.
Plus a momma and a daddy milk mug.
Milk mugs, these kinda like
cloudy milk mugs are beast.
- [Lou] So it was $3 for those three?
- It was, no, a dollar for the three.
We did it out here, got this
red light, Lou, tell 'em.
- [Lou] How'd you beat me here?
- 'Cause I'm quick like that.
- I guess so.
- I'm a gangster, old school.
How we doin', did we hit it?
- We did really good.
- All right, guys, episode four
of Trash Talk in the books, crushed it,
let's go through the
recap, had a great day,
four hours of driving, $25 in
gas, yes, they pay shipping.
Let's get into the recap.
I paid 10 bucks for this
jacket, it's priceless.
Picked up this Playboy
poker set for a buck
and it's 11.
Got a huge bag of ponies,
34 of 'em for 50 bucks,
about a buck 33 a pop,
when it's all broken down
based on what I'm seeing
I'm gonna range this at,
125 to 175 bucks.
♪ Just in case I wanna buy shit ♪
♪ I been moving with a shooter ♪
- Picked up this vintage Disney book,
it's banged up a bit, picked
it up for three, let's go 20.
Got this Build-a-Bear husky
with a little baby in the mouth,
paid a buck, ripped that
Patriot fan off, it goes for 19.
That same Pats fan, I took
these Yankee teddy bears,
three of 'em, let's go 10 on
that, and here's the third one,
and the other black lab with his baby,
let's go 10 on that so 20 there.
Picked up these three Adventures
of Link Nintendo games,
one in box, mint, two
clean mint games, mint,
I'm gonna go 35 actually
a piece on these and 80,
I think it's, 70 and 30, 130, this is 150,
paid 10 bucks for all three, 3.33 a piece,
150 on the flip, classic vintage Nintendo.
I paid 10 for these four epic DS games,
they'll go for a buck and a quarter.
Paid a dollar, 33 cents a pop
for this Strawberry Shortcake
and mom and dad milk mugs,
milk mugs are these creamy
kind of ceramic thing,
20, 15, 35 on the flip.
Picked up this Michael Jordan
thing, poster, vintage, $3,
50 to 200 bucks.
It's 3:30 in the morning, I'm
flying from Qatar to New York
and I just got this $175
offer, I'm not gonna take it.
♪ Dance, make him blow them bands ♪
♪ Dance, dance, dance, dance ♪
- Scored an insane amount of Nerf guns.
Paid 20 for 'em, I think
you're looking at at least,
I mean, what do you think,
Little Lou, 200, maybe 250?
250 at least, might be 300,
this is a massive score.
Lookin' at 250 to 300 on the flip.
Nerf guns for days on the flip.
♪ My momma always told
me just to go for it ♪
♪ Every time they see
me they say oh lord ♪
♪ It is what it is so
why you so mad at me ♪
♪ Bothered so many rappers ♪
♪ That they all started callin' me dad ♪
♪ Who wanna bat at me,
somebody will end up dead ♪